We all know how it is today. For most of the year, medical experts and government officials told us all to wear face masks. Half of us don't do it. Now that we finally have a vaccine, a third are hesitant to take it or say they definitely will not take it. But it wasn't always like this. Americans used to do what they were asked by medical authorities, mostly. Like when the 1918 flu pandemic hit the United States, killing similar numbers of Americans that COVID is killing today. Let's look at one American city that did a pretty good job minimizing deaths back then. Howard Markel writes about the history of American epidemics.
我们都知道今天的情况。在一年中的大部分时间里，医学专家和政府官员都告诉我们每个人要戴口罩。我们有一半人没有这样做。现在我们终于有了疫苗，又有三分之一的人对是否接种犹豫不决，或者明确表示他们绝对不会接种。但情况并非总是如此。美国人过去通常会听从医疗当局的建议。就像1918年流感大流行袭击美国时，死亡的美国人数与今天新冠病毒造成的死亡人数相当。让我们看看当时一个在最大限度减少死亡方面做得相当不错的美国城市。霍华德·马凯尔（Howard Markel）撰写过关于美国流行病历史的文章。
So a great example, the example I love to use, is St. Louis, Missouri. And they had a very adept commissioner of health named Max Starkloff.
一个很好的例子，我喜欢用的例子，就是密苏里州的圣路易斯。他们有一位非常能干的卫生专员，名叫马克斯·斯塔克洛夫（Max Starkloff）。
Commissioner of health is the local official, usually a doctor, who tells everybody what to do when there's an epidemic or other health emergency. For instance, Max Starkloff closed schools. He ended public gatherings of all sorts. He ordered people who were sick to be quarantined. Dr. Starkloff was a good political operator.
卫生专员是当地的官员，通常是一名医生，负责在疫情或其他卫生紧急情况发生时告诉大家该怎么做。例如，马克斯·斯塔克洛夫关闭了学校。他停止了各种公众集会。他下令对病人进行隔离。斯塔克洛夫医生是一位出色的政治操盘手。
But he was also very good at communicating to the public and made twice-daily statements that were reported in the newspapers. And you have to remember, back then, most newspapers had six or more editions per day. So they updated them, much like CNN would update its stories.
但他也非常擅长与公众沟通，他每天发表两次声明，并由报纸报道。你必须记住，当时大多数报纸每天有六个或更多的版面。所以他们会更新这些信息，就像美国有线电视新闻网（CNN）更新新闻一样。
What was his messaging? Do you know?
他的传达信息是什么？你知道吗？
Yeah, it was like, be a good St. Louisian, I remember. You know, and don't spread the flu. It is a socially mediated disease, and we've got to work together.
是的，就像是“做一个好的圣路易斯人”，我记得。你知道，不要传播流感。这是一种社会性传播的疾病，我们必须共同努力。
Howard says Dr. Starkloff had all kinds of messages, telling people to wash their hands, don't cough on others. And because medicine was so primitive back then, they hadn't actually isolated the flu virus. So they had no way to confirm if you had it. They couldn't test you. So the only way they could keep track of the disease was that people who were sneezing and sick told authorities. So Starkloff would tell the public--
霍华德说斯塔克洛夫医生有各种各样的信息，告诉人们要洗手，不要对着别人咳嗽。由于当时的医学还很原始，他们实际上还没有分离出流感病毒。所以他们没有办法确认你是否患病。他们无法对你进行检测。因此，他们追踪这种疾病的唯一方法就是通过那些打喷嚏和生病的人主动告诉当局。所以斯塔克洛夫会告诉公众——
These are the symptoms that you need to call us about. You need to communicate this to us. That's where the word "communicable disease" comes from, by the way. Not so much that it's infectious, even though it is, but that one source is communicating it to a higher source and to a public health department.
这些就是你需要联系我们的症状。你需要把这些情况告诉我们。顺便说一下，“传染病”（communicable disease）这个词就是这么来的。这不仅仅是因为它具有传染性，尽管事实确实如此，而是因为一个源头正在将其传达给更高一级的源头和公共卫生部门。
Oh, wow.
哦，哇。
Yeah. So that works because if you can get people on board with that, they're self-isolating, they're self-reporting, they're self-quarantining and so on. So that's good.
是的。这之所以有效，是因为如果你能让人们参与其中，他们就会自我隔离、自我报告、自我检疫等等。所以这很好。
To be clear, not everybody was on board. There's pushback from the public in every American epidemic, Howard says. German immigrants rioted rather than get vaccinated in the 1880s. During the 1918 flu, 2,000 people showed up to protest a mandatory face mask law in California. But mostly, Howard Markel says, people complied. He says they trusted scientists more back then, even though scientists knew so much less than they know today.
需要明确的是，并非每个人都愿意配合。霍华德说，在每一次美国流行病中，都会有来自公众的抵制。19世纪80年代，德国移民宁愿暴动也不愿接种疫苗。1918年流感期间，有2000人站出来抗议加利福尼亚州的强制口罩令。但霍华德·马凯尔说，大多数人还是遵守了。他说，尽管当时科学家了解的知识远不如今天，但人们当时更信任科学家。
And also, remember, 1918, the country was at war. It was World War I. So there's a lot of patriotic "let's all pull together" feeling in the country. But maybe the biggest reason that people listened to public health authorities back in 1918-- self-interest. Avoiding public gatherings, quarantines, that was about all you could do to protect yourself and your loved ones, given the state of medicine back then.
而且还要记住，1918年，国家正处于战争状态。那是第一次世界大战。所以国家有一种强烈的爱国主义“让我们团结一致”的情绪。但也许人们在1918年听从公共卫生当局的最大原因是——个人利益。考虑到当时的医疗状况，避免公共集会、隔离，是你保护自己和所爱之人所能做的全部事情。
Most everybody knew somebody who'd died of an infectious disease, Howard says. Two of five babies died before their fifth birthday, many of them from infectious diseases. And Howard says epidemics were coming through every year or so, diseases we had no treatment for.
霍华德说，几乎每个人都认识死于传染病的人。五个婴儿中有两个在五岁生日前死亡，其中许多死于传染病。霍华德说，流行病大约每隔一年左右就会爆发一次，我们对此类疾病毫无治疗办法。
Yeah, whether there was a diphtheria or a whooping cough epidemic, or occasional smallpox epidemics, or measles epidemics, you know, they were frequent enough that you were quite used to epidemics, particularly if you were a parent.
是的，无论是白喉、百日咳疫情，还是偶尔爆发的天花或麻疹疫情，你知道，这些疫情非常频繁，以至于你对流行病已经习以为常了，特别是如果你是一位家长的话。
And used to the tactics to deal with them, used to quarantining and isolating and all that.
并且习惯了应对它们的策略，习惯了检疫、隔离等等。
Right, because you didn't have anything else.
是的，因为你别无选择。
This is before the age of antibiotics. That doesn't happen till the 1940s. Antivirals don't come till way after that. I think all of us living today, when so many diseases are treatable, I think we forget what a different world that was. Like for instance, if you got tuberculosis in New York City in the 1940s, they would send you to a TB ward to keep you from infecting anybody else.
这是在抗生素时代之前。直到20世纪40年代才出现抗生素。抗病毒药物则要晚得多。我想我们今天生活的所有人，在这么多疾病都可以治疗的情况下，可能忘记了那是一个多么不同的世界。例如，如果你在20世纪40年代的纽约市得了肺结核，他们会把你送到肺结核病房，以防止你传染给其他人。
I had a neighbor who was born in 1927, and she told me as a kid, when she got the disease, she was sent to one of those wards to live on the Upper West Side. The building's actually still there. She said they told her when she arrived, "OK, we don't know how to cure this, but we do know how to make you comfortable. Some of you live, and some of you die. Good luck."
我有一位1927年出生的邻居，她告诉我，小时候当她得了这种病时，她被送到了上西区的一个病房生活。那栋建筑现在还在。她说当她到达时，他们告诉她：“好吧，我们不知道怎么治愈这个，但我们知道如何让你感到舒适。有些人活下来了，有些人死了。祝你好运。”
Today, of course, things are so different. Howard Markel says there's never been an epidemic in America like the one we're going through right now.
今天，当然，情况大不相同了。霍华德·马凯尔说，美国从未发生过像我们现在正在经历的这样的流行病。
None. None have come close to being as politicized, as red versus blue, on even the most mundane of scientific matters than this pandemic.
没有。没有任何一次流行病像这次这样被政治化，在哪怕是最普通的科学问题上也被划分为红色阵营和蓝色阵营。
Yeah, yeah.
是的，是的。
Not even close. It feels as if it's so baked in to the ideologies of so many Americans right now, it feels almost hopeless.
根本无法相比。这感觉好像已经深深嵌入了现在许多美国人的意识形态中，感觉几乎毫无希望。
Well, today on our program, we have stories of public health experts trying to protect the public, telling us all to do things that will save our lives in this moment when unprecedented numbers of us are not obeying them.
好吧，在今天的节目中，我们会有一些公共卫生专家试图保护公众的故事，他们告诉我们每个人去做那些能挽救生命的事情，而此时此刻，前所未有的很多人并没有听从他们的建议。
We have two stories today. The first is about what it's like to do these jobs while getting so much pushback. The second, an expert on how to get through to Republican voters tries to convince them to take the vaccine, which is not easy.
我们今天有两个故事。第一个是关于在受到如此多抵制的情况下从事这些工作是什么样的感受。第二个故事是一位向共和党选民传达信息的专家试图说服他们接种疫苗，这并不容易。
WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Stay with us.
芝加哥WBEZ广播电台，这是《这个美国生活》（This American Life）。我是艾拉·格拉斯（Ira Glass）。请留在这里。
Act 1, Hazardous to Your Health Official.
第一幕，对你的卫生官员来说很危险。
So the way the system works in our country is that there are thousands of local public health officials in cities and counties across the country. In normal times, they test our drinking water. They make sure restaurants are sanitary. They enforce smoking bans, control mosquito populations in some places, run education campaigns, like nutrition programs for new mothers. The specifics vary a little from state to state, but you get the idea. They oversee health conditions.
在我们国家，这个系统的运作方式是，全国各地的城市和县都有成千上万名地方公共卫生官员。在正常时期，他们检测我们的饮用水。他们确保餐馆卫生。他们在一些地方强制执行禁烟令，控制蚊虫数量，开展教育活动，比如为新妈妈提供营养项目。具体的职责因州而异，但你明白我的意思。他们监督健康状况。
And when there's a health emergency, like the outbreak of an infectious disease, they get special powers, broad powers to quarantine, close down businesses, do what's necessary to keep it from spreading. And they're obligated to take action. This past year, like I've said, the public that they're protecting has made all that a lot harder to do.
而当发生卫生紧急情况时，比如传染病爆发，他们就会获得特殊的权力，广泛的权力来实施检疫、关闭企业，采取一切必要措施防止扩散。而且他们有义务采取行动。就像我说过的，过去一年里，他们所保护的公众让这一切变得困难得多。
Keep in mind, these are not elected officials. They are public servants. They're government employees. Anna Maria Barry-Jester, a reporter with Kaiser Health News, has a story about two of these public health officials in Santa Cruz County in California, where she lives.
记住，这些不是民选官员。他们是公务员。他们是政府雇员。凯撒健康新闻（Kaiser Health News）的记者安娜·玛丽亚·巴里-杰斯特（Anna Maria Barry-Jester）讲述了她居住的加利福尼亚州圣克鲁斯县两名公共卫生官员的故事。
A heads-up before we start-- some things in this story may not be right for children to hear. Here's Anna.
在开始之前提醒一下——这个故事中的一些内容可能不适合儿童收听。下面请听安娜的报道。
I've spent the last year talking to dozens of public health officials all over the country. I'd call to ask about COVID testing, contact tracing, or some other issue I was reporting on. And they'd often make an offhand comment about getting threatening calls in the middle of the night, or emails that had detailed photos of their house with messages like "Look out, we're coming for you."
过去一年里，我采访了全国各地的几十名公共卫生官员。我会打电话询问有关新冠检测、接触者追踪或其他我正在报道的问题。他们通常会随口提到在半夜接到威胁电话，或者电子邮件里带有他们房子的详细照片，并附上类似“小心，我们要去找你了”这样的信息。
Most of these public health people didn't want to go into detail about it on the record. It was too scary. They worried that it would only make them bigger targets. But these two officials in Santa Cruz County stood out, because they not only agreed to talk, they were unusually candid.
大多数这些公共卫生人员不想在公开记录中谈论细节。这太可怕了。他们担心这只会让他们成为更大的目标。但圣克鲁斯县的这两位官员表现得很突出，因为他们不仅同意接受采访，而且格外坦率。
The first official I'm going to tell you about is Dr. Gail Newel. She's the county's health officer, sort of like the Fauci of Santa Cruz, but with more power. She writes the orders requiring masks, closing bars and restaurants. She's the public face of the COVID response. Gail is what you want in a health officer-- no nonsense, uncompromising. In meetings with elected officials, she's known for shutting them down if they ask her to do something she doesn't think is right.
我要告诉你的第一位官员是盖尔·纽厄尔（Gail Newel）医生。她是该县的卫生官，有点像是圣克鲁斯的福奇，但拥有更大的权力。她签署要求戴口罩、关闭酒吧和餐馆的行政命令。她是新冠应对工作的公众形象。盖尔正是你想要的那种卫生官——务实、绝不妥协。在与民选官员的会议上，如果他们要求她做她认为不正确的事情，她以直接打断对方而闻名。
She just says--
她只会说——
It's not going to happen as long as I'm health officer.
只要我是卫生官，这就不可能发生。
How is that received?
这反应如何？
I think-- I don't like to use that as a threat. But on the other hand, I'm really stubbornly persistent.
我想——我不喜欢把这当作威胁。但另一方面，我真的很顽固。
[CHUCKLING]
[轻笑]
And I really do believe that I'm in the right place at the right time to be of service to the community during this pandemic in this way.
我确实相信，在这场大流行期间，我处于正确的时间和地点，能够以这种方式为社区服务。
When the pandemic hit last spring, Santa Cruz County was a total success story. Gail ordered one of the country's first stay-at-home orders on March 16, when the federal government was still telling us not to wear masks and President Trump was suggesting COVID would just disappear with warmer weather.
去年春天疫情爆发时，圣克鲁斯县是一个完全成功的案例。3月16日，当联邦政府还在告诉我们不要戴口罩，特朗普总统还暗示新冠病毒会随着天气变暖而消失时，盖尔就下达了全国首批居家令之一。
While COVID case numbers and deaths shot up in New York New, Orleans, and Detroit, the numbers in Santa Cruz County stayed very low. But at public meetings, Gail started seeing a level of anger she hadn't seen before in her career.
虽然纽约、新奥尔良和底特律的新冠病例数和死亡人数激增，但圣克鲁斯县的数字一直非常低。但在公开会议上，盖尔开始看到她职业生涯中从未见过的愤怒程度。
Wow. Y'all supervisors are such uncaring assholes. This whole shelter in place is complete bullshit. Like, you and you are just terrible at your jobs.
哇。你们这些主管真是麻木不仁的混蛋。整个居家令完全是胡扯。比如，你和你们，你们的工作做得太糟糕了。
This guy pointed at Gail. Santa Cruz County is lined with beaches. It's a place with a boardwalk, and roller coasters, and a big surf scene. Gail closed them down to keep tourists away.
这个家伙指着盖尔。圣克鲁斯县到处是海滩。这里有木板路、过山车和一个大型冲浪胜地。盖尔为了让游客远离而关闭了它们。
You have to allow police officers to basically be walking fascists. They have to go around and harass peaceful people for being on a beach, for being outside, for, like, hanging out with your friends. What good is being alive if you can't do anything? You want me to stay inside, get fat, watch Netflix, and masturbate? That's literally all you are allowing us to do. Your hands are not tied, Dr. Newel. Grow a spine!
你们必须允许警察基本上成为行走的法西斯主义者。他们必须到处骚扰在海滩上、在户外、像和朋友们聚在一起这样平静的人。如果你什么都不能做，活着有什么意义？你想让我呆在家里，变胖，看网飞（Netflix），然后自慰吗？这就是你允许我们做的全部事情。盖尔·纽厄尔医生，你的手没有被束缚。拿出点骨气来！
In the spring, there were only a handful of COVID cases each week. Only two people in a county of more than a quarter million had died. But this crowd didn't see that as evidence of a job well done by Gail.
春天时，每周只有少数几个新冠病例。在一个拥有超过25万人口的县里，只有两个人死亡。但这群人并不认为这是盖尔工作出色的证据。
You are shutting down Santa Cruz because of two deaths. I don't care about how many tests there are. People are wandering around not dying. This is fraud, economic terrorism.
你们因为两起死亡事件就关闭了圣克鲁斯。我不在乎有多少检测。人们在到处走动，并没有死。这是欺诈，是经济恐怖主义。
The people going after Gail at these meetings were a small but vocal group. Many of them were from the north and central parts of the county, which are affluent and majority white. They weren't the people getting sick from COVID. Those cases were mostly in south county, which is majority Latino and where a lot of agricultural workers live.
在这些会议上攻击盖尔的人是一个小众但声音很大的群体。他们中的许多人来自该县的北部和中部，那里是富裕地区，白人居多。他们不是感染新冠的人。那些病例主要在南县，那里以拉丁裔为主，住着许多农业工人。
Protesters were hijacking public meetings like this all over the country. Gail wasn't terribly concerned. She kept forging ahead with her job, giving press conferences and pulling all-nighters. Then in early May, the protests escalated from public to private. After weeks of getting nasty emails and voicemails from strangers, one Sunday Gail was taking an afternoon nap to recover from her 80-hour workweek. She called it her COVID Sabbath.
抗议者在全国各地的公共会议上闹事。盖尔并不是特别担心。她继续推进她的工作，召开新闻发布会，通宵工作。然后在5月初，抗议活动从公共场合升级到了私人生活。在连续几周收到陌生人的恶毒邮件和语音留言后，一个周日，盖尔为了从每周80小时的工作中恢复过来，正在睡午觉。她称之为她的“新冠安息日”。
And all of a sudden, I heard all this racket. And so I peeped through a window and saw the group out in front. And they were singing, playing guitars, playing ukulele.
突然，我听到了一阵喧闹声。我从窗户往外看，看到了前边的那群人。他们在唱歌，弹吉他，弹尤克里里。
(SINGING) Gail to jail!
（歌唱）盖尔进监狱！
They're singing "Gail to jail." This is from a video the protesters posted online.
他们在唱“盖尔进监狱”。这是抗议者发布在网上的视频。
In some ways, it was amusing and creative. But then they would gather around my home on all sides and yell out threatening things.
从某些方面来说，这很有趣也很有创意。但随后他们会聚集在我家的四周围，大声叫喊威胁的话语。
Take her to jail. She's a criminal!
把她送进监狱。她是罪犯！
She called 911 twice but got a busy signal. So she called the sheriff on his cell phone. He sent patrol cars to her house.
她两次拨打911，但都占线。所以她打了治安官的手机。他派了巡逻车到她家。
I mean, I'm willing to be a public servant. But I don't think that that includes having people trespass onto my private property and to disturb my Sunday afternoon nap in a way that felt dangerous to me. So I was quite worried for my family, and for myself, and our safety.
我的意思是，我愿意成为一名公务员。但我认为这不包括让人闯入我的私人财产，并以一种让我感到危险的方式打扰我的周日下午午睡。所以我非常担心我的家人、我自己和我们的安全。
Protesters with ukuleles and flip-flops is very Santa Cruz. The county's about an hour south of San Francisco, with a stereotype as a crunchy, peace-loving, lefty paradise. But these protesters were aggressive. They broke down the gate to her neighborhood to get to her house. They showed up with bullhorns and sirens every Sunday for a month. The sheriff's department started sending regular patrols past Gail's house.
带着尤克里里和人字拖的抗议者非常有“圣克鲁斯风格”。该县位于旧金山以南约一小时路程，一直被刻板印象为一块充满爱心的左翼天堂。但这些抗议者很激进。他们冲破了她社区的大门来到她家门口。他们连续一个月每个周日都带着扩音器和警笛出现。治安官部门开始派人定期在盖尔家巡逻。
Then late in May, the next escalation happened at a public meeting in a packed room. A man started walking up to the podium, and then made a beeline for Gail and lunged at her.
5月下旬，下一次升级发生在一次拥挤的房间里的公开会议上。一个男人开始走向讲台，然后径直朝盖尔走去，并向她猛扑过去。
Clear the room. Excuse me. Chair, I'd ask that you clear the room.
清空房间。对不起。主席，我请求你清空房间。
That's a county official evacuating the room.
那是县官员在疏散房间。
Clear the room. Clear the room.
清空房间。清空房间。
Two sheriff's deputies surrounded the man.
两名治安官代表包围了那个男人。
We're not going to accept that kind of behavior.
我们不会接受那种行为。
We'll take a five-minute recess.
我们要休会五分钟。
Take a recess, and we are clearing the room.
休会，我们正在清空房间。
It happened so quickly that I didn't really know what was going on. And then suddenly I was surrounded by sheriff's deputies, and I was escorted out of the building. And I was told by the sheriff that I couldn't come to any more in-person meetings anymore.
事情发生得太快了，我根本不知道发生了什么。然后我突然被治安官代表包围，我被护送出了大楼。治安官告诉我，我不能再参加任何现场会议了。
The sheriff told you to do that? Can you tell me about that conversation?
治安官让你这么做的？你能告诉我关于那次谈话的情况吗？
Yeah, so the sheriff said that he didn't feel confident that he and his deputies would be able to protect me in public venues any longer, and that he recommended that I not appear in public anymore in meetings, where people would know where I was.
是的，治安官说他不再有信心能保护我在公共场所的安全，他建议我以后不要再出现在公共会议上，因为人们会知道我在哪里。
Gail was now a public servant who could no longer appear before the public. She took the sheriff's advice to stop appearing in person at public meetings. She and the sheriff had a good relationship. She trusted his advice. And notably, he had enforced her lockdown orders. The county government had backed her up, too. Maybe that shouldn't sound remarkable, but it is. In some other parts of the country, sheriffs and local governments were publicly disregarding their health officials' orders.
盖尔现在成了一名无法再面对公众的公务员。她听从了治安官的建议，停止亲自参加公开会议。她和治安官关系很好。她信任他的建议。值得注意的是，他也曾执行过她的封锁令。县政府也支持她。这听起来可能不值得一提，但事实并非如此。在全国其他一些地方，治安官和地方政府正在公开无视其卫生官员的命令。
The second health official I'm going to tell you about is Gail's boss, director Mimi Hall. If Gail's the Tony Fauci of Santa Cruz, always on TV, Mimi's the bureaucrat behind the scenes. She runs the entire health department, and has spent her whole 27-year career working in public health. She's a true believer, the kind of person who gets visibly excited talking about bureaucratic changes that make it easier to enroll in Medicaid.
我要告诉你的第二位卫生官员是盖尔的老板，局长咪咪·霍尔（Mimi Hall）。如果说盖尔是圣克鲁斯的安东尼·福奇，经常出现在电视上，那么咪咪就是幕后的官僚。她管理着整个卫生部门，并在公共卫生领域工作了27年的整个职业生涯。她是一位真正的信徒，那种谈论起让医疗补助登记更容易的官僚改革时会明显兴奋的人。
And she navigated the threats she was getting differently from Gail. Gail tends to be pretty cut and dry. Mimi is the feelings person. She has empathy for people, even when they're yelling obscenities at her.
她处理威胁的方式与盖尔不同。盖尔往往非常干脆利落。咪咪是个感性的人。她对人们有同情心，即使当他们对她大喊大叫辱骂时。
My feelings of discomfort were coupled with compassion. And so while there were words used like "communist" and "tyrant" and "fascist" and a lot of accusations that there really wasn't a pandemic, I could always understand that these people came from their own place of fear, discomfort, anger, all of those things. And people need a place to put that.
我的不适感与同情心并存。所以虽然有人使用“共产主义者”、“暴君”、“法西斯”这样的词，还有很多指责说根本没有流行病，但我总是能理解这些人源于他们内心的恐惧、不适、愤怒，所有这些情绪。人们需要一个地方来发泄这些。
Mimi was at that May meeting with Gail. On the one hand, she felt worried. But also, she wasn't sure what to make of it.
咪咪和盖尔参加了那次5月的会议。一方面，她感到担心。但同时，她也不确定该怎么看待这件事。
The day that the person had lunged at her in the boardroom, you know, we were offered sheriff's deputies escorts back to our office. Which we appreciated. And then we were both offered escorts back home, and I declined. And part of the reason I declined is, you're not sure, is it really dangerous? You feel this feeling of, well, maybe we're overreacting. You know, and you feel kind of silly.
在董事会上那个人向她扑过来的那天，你知道，我们被提供了治安官代表护送回我们的办公室。我们对此表示感谢。然后我们两人都被提供了护送回家的服务，但我拒绝了。我拒绝的部分原因是，你不确定，这真的有那么危险吗？你有一种感觉，嗯，也许我们反应过度了。你知道，你会觉得自己有点傻。
Feeling silly or not, she did take some basic precautions. She started leaving her office at the county building every day by 7:00 PM. That's when security guards left for the day.
无论是否觉得傻，她确实采取了一些基本的预防措施。她开始每天下午7点离开她在县政府大楼的办公室。那时候保安会下班。
That was kind of like my ticking time clock, right? And I have this habit of calling my husband from my office before I go down the stairs. And then we stay on the phone until I get to the bottom of the stairwell, and then walk to my car. My car door's closed, and it's locked.
这就像我的倒计时时钟，对吧？我有一个习惯，在下楼梯之前从办公室给我的丈夫打电话。然后我们保持通话，直到我走到楼梯底部，然后走到我的车里。我的车门关上并锁好了。
All over the country, opposition to mask mandates and stay-at-home orders have been drawing together groups that didn't normally see eye to eye. Lefty radicals and right wing extremists, libertarians and mom groups, small business owners and anti-vaxxers, they started adopting each other's rhetoric. On social media, anti-vaxxers posed with rifles and offered firearms training. This all made the landscaper of who was lobbing the threats and what they were capable of even murkier and scarier.
在全国各地，对口罩令的反对和居家令把平时不和的人群聚集在一起。左翼激进分子和右翼极端分子、自由意志主义者和妈妈团体、小企业主和反疫苗者，他们开始采纳彼此的言论。在社交媒体上，反疫苗者摆出步枪姿势并提供枪支训练。这一切使得谁在制造威胁以及他们有能力做什么的景观变得更加模糊和可怕。
In June, things got much worse. A colleague of Mimi's, a sheriff's deputy, was killed when he was out on a call. This happened less than two miles from her home in the Santa Cruz mountains. According to court records, a man linked to the Boogaloo Boys, an anti-government extremist group that wants to incite a civil war, shot at the deputy and other officers with an automatic rifle and threw a pipe bomb.
6月，情况变得更糟了。咪咪的一位同事，一名治安官代表，在出勤时被杀。这发生在离她在圣克鲁斯山脉的家不到两英里远的地方。根据法庭记录，一名与“Boogaloo Boys”（一个想煽动内战的反政府极端组织）有关的男子用自动步枪向该代表和其他警察开枪，并投掷了一枚管状炸弹。
Before this man was arrested, he got hit with crossfire and used his own blood to write a "Boog" on the hood of a car. Mimi saw ambulances and police cars rushing to the scene, and was stunned to find out that the alleged gunman lives so close to her and was an active duty sergeant in the Air Force. He's pleaded not guilty to murder.
在这个人被捕之前，他在交火中中弹，并用自己的血在汽车引擎盖上写下了“Boog”字样。咪咪看到救护车和警车赶往现场，震惊地发现那个被指控的枪手住得离她如此之近，而且是一名空军现役中士。他已对谋杀指控表示不认罪。
I started wondering who around me thinks this way, and how close are they? And so immediately we installed more-- we installed security cameras. And when we first installed those, I was looking at them constantly. It was like an obsession. When I was at work, oh, my gosh. That made me so nervous for the kids to be at home. I was a nervous wreck.
我开始怀疑周围有谁会这样想，他们离我有多近？所以我们立即安装了更多——我们安装了安全摄像头。当我们刚装好这些时，我一直在不停地看。这就像一种强迫症。当我在工作时，天哪。这让我非常担心孩子们在家里。我成了一个神经质的残骸。
Mimi urged Gail to get security cameras, and couldn't believe how long it took her to install them. When the sheriff recommended they both get guns and firearm training, Mimi brought home a shotgun and built gates across her driveway. Gail didn't get a gun. Here's what Gail said about that decision.
咪咪敦促盖尔安装安全摄像头，并无法相信她花了好久才装上。当治安官建议她们都去买枪并进行枪支训练时，咪咪带了一把猎枪回家，并在车道上装了大门。盖尔没有买枪。这是盖尔对那个决定的说法。
I know the public health statistics. You know you're far more likely to die from a gunshot wound if you have a gun in the home. And I don't want to take that risk. I was also raised Mennonite, so I have very strong pacifist beliefs. I wouldn't ever have a gun in my home. And he recommended that I get a big dog. He asked me about my dog. And I said, well, he's deaf and he has no teeth.
我知道公共卫生统计数据。你知道如果你家里有枪，你死于枪伤的可能性要高得多。我不想冒那个险。我还是门诺派教徒出身，所以我有着非常强烈的和平主义信仰。我家里永远不会有枪。他建议我买一条大狗。他问我关于我的狗的情况。我说，嗯，它是聋子，而且没有牙。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
So he won't be very helpful.
所以他不会很有帮助。
Did you get the dog?
你买那条狗了吗？
I did not get the dog, either. We still have the old deaf dog. We have some pretty ferocious cats, though.
我也没有买那条狗。我们仍然养着那只又老又聋的狗。不过，我们有几只相当凶猛的猫。
There's a privacy law in California that shields the home addresses of domestic abuse survivors and abortion providers. Last year, the governor expanded it to public health officials. Mimi signed up. Gail did, too. The fact that it all got to this point surprised Mimi. She'd moved to Santa Cruz because she saw it as a refuge for her family.
加利福尼亚州有一项隐私法，保护家庭暴力幸存者和堕胎提供者的家庭住址。去年，州长将其范围扩大到了公共卫生官员。咪咪登记了。盖尔也登记了。这一切发展到这一步让咪咪感到惊讶。她搬到圣克鲁斯是因为她把它视为家人的避风港。
They used to live in Plumas, a politically conservative and white county in northern California. She ran the public health department there, and was constantly fighting with officials, especially when she had to roll out Obamacare. She told me they were also dealing with a lot of racism. She and her kids are Burmese American. They all hoped for a more peaceful life when they moved to liberal Santa Cruz. I talked to Mimi about this.
他们曾经住在普卢马斯，那是加州北部一个政治保守且以白人为主的县。她在那里管理公共卫生部门，并不断与官员争吵，特别是在她不得不推出奥巴马医改（Obamacare）时。她告诉我，他们还在处理大量的种族主义问题。她和她的孩子们是缅甸裔美国人。他们都希望搬到自由派圣克鲁斯后能过上更平静的生活。我和咪咪谈到了这件事。
And until that period, until this period, how had you seen yourself in the community and your role in it?
在那段时期之前，你怎么看待你在社区中的角色以及你在其中的位置？
I just saw myself as a regular community member and a mom and a wife and a-- you know. I just lived my life. And it's really changed how free I feel to, like, be my authentic self in the community. You know, after Deputy Gutzwiller's death, so my daughter had made a Black Lives Matter sign and put it on the outside of our fence. And then we had a sign celebrating my other daughter's graduation. And it had her name on it. We took all of those down. Like, we just had nothing that said what we believe in or what we stand for. Nothing.
我只是把自己看作一个普通的社区成员、妈妈、妻子和——你知道的。我只是过我的生活。这真的改变了我作为一个真实的自己在社区里感到多自由。你知道，在古茨威勒（Gutzwiller）代表去世后，我的女儿做了一个“黑人的命也是命”（Black Lives Matter）的标志，把它贴在了我们的栅栏外面。然后我们还有一个庆祝我另一个女儿毕业的标志。上面有她的名字。我们把所有这些都拿掉了。我们没有任何标志表明我们的信仰或立场。什么都没有。
The majority of local public health officials in the country are women. I've talked to lots of them, and there's a recurring pattern. The harassment and threats they've been getting this year come almost exclusively from men. They're regularly called bitches and threatened with death. Their children and spouses are called out by name. Armed men have openly carried weapons outside of some of their homes.
该国大多数地方公共卫生官员是女性。我采访过很多，有一个反复出现的模式。他们今年受到的骚扰和威胁几乎全部来自男性。她们经常被称为“婊子”，并受到死亡威胁。她们的孩子和配偶被指名道姓地攻击。武装男子在她们家外公开携带武器。
I didn't hear about that kind of harassment at all from their male colleagues. In the county next door to Santa Cruz, Santa Clara County, a female health officer got a steady stream of anonymous hate mail and death threats police believe came from a man with suspected ties to the Boogaloo Boys. Some of the letters had a Santa Claus stamp and an igloo, which is a known symbol for the movement.
我根本没有听到她们的男性同事提到过那种骚扰。在圣克鲁斯隔壁的圣克拉拉县，一位女性卫生官收到了一连串匿名的仇恨邮件和死亡威胁，警方认为这些威胁来自一名与Boogaloo Boys有嫌疑的男子。有些信件上有圣诞老人邮票和一个冰屋，这是该运动的已知象征。
He included pornographic images of women and called her a "Hitler bitch." Then in July, about a month after the Sheriff's deputy was killed, Mimi got a letter with a Santa Claus stamp, too. Police believe it's from the same man.
他包括了女性的色情图片，并称她为“希特勒婊子”。然后在7月，也就是那位治安官代表被杀大约一个月后，咪咪也收到了一封带有圣诞老人邮票的信。警方认为它来自同一个男人。
So it started off with "Hey, C-U-N-T." I mean, that's how it was addressed.
所以它开始于“嘿，C-U-N-T（荡妇）”。我的意思是，这就是它的称呼。
Wow.
哇。
[SIGHS]
[叹气]
And this letter was different because it said "I've shared your information widely on social media and among all my contacts." And one of the closing points in the letter said something like me dying a really slow death, and that he would enjoy that.
这封信之所以不同，是因为它说“我在社交媒体和我的所有联系人中广泛分享了你的信息”。信中的结束语之一是说我死得非常缓慢，他会很享受。
She immediately called the sheriff's department and spoke with a deputy.
她立即拨打了治安官部门的电话，并与一名代表交谈。
What he told me was, he said, you know what? We've been following this guy for a while. We know who he is. We know where he works. Like, they knew who he was. They told me he lived in Gilroy. The FBI is involved. You know, he felt like they had good eyes on this person. So he wanted me to know that. So I felt a comfort level, that it wasn't just some random person out there and they had no idea.
他告诉我说，他说，你知道吗？我们跟踪这个家伙有一段时间了。我们知道他是谁。我们知道他在哪里工作。他们知道他是谁。他们告诉我他住在吉尔罗伊（Gilroy）。联邦调查局（FBI）也参与其中。他觉得他们已经很好地监视了这个人的动向。所以他想让我知道这一点。所以我感到一种安慰，那不仅仅是一个他们毫无头绪的随机人物。
But then one of the things that really struck me is he also said, Yeah, I don't think he's a huge threat. And he said, he's a dad. He has kids. He has a professional job, and he drives a Tesla. As if any of those things make you less dangerous or less, you know, out there. And I was just like--
但随后让我感到非常震惊的一件事是，他还说：“是的，我不认为他是个巨大的威胁。”他说，“他是一个父亲。他有孩子。他有一份专业的工作，他开特斯拉。”就好像这些事情中的任何一件会让你变得不那么危险，或者不那么……你知道，不那么疯狂。我当时就想——
What were you thinking?
你在想什么？
I was like, opposite profiling. A white gentleman with a professional job who drives a Tesla? And then I thought, well, maybe he was telling me that just to make me feel better, you know? I don't know, but that's what he told me, and it did not make me feel better.
我在想，“反向画像”。一个有专业工作的白人绅士，开着特斯拉？然后我想，好吧，也许他这么告诉我只是为了让我感觉好一点，你知道？我不知道，但他确实是这么告诉我的，这并没有让我感觉好一点。
Shortly after, officers arrested the guy after they watched him drop another letter in the mail. When they searched his home, they found 150 firearms, including semi-automatic rifles, thousands of rounds of ammunition, and materials for explosives. He's pleaded not guilty to charges of stalking and threatening a public employee.
不久之后，警察在观察那个人把另一封信丢进邮箱后将他逮捕。当他们搜查他的家时，他们发现了150件枪支，包括半自动步枪、数千发弹药和爆炸物材料。他已对跟踪和威胁公务员的指控表示不认罪。
After the Santa Claus letter, Mimi basically stopped leaving her house. She wouldn't even go to her kid's school events on Zoom, in case the other parents recognized her. And when she did have to go to the grocery store, she went incognito-- mask, hat, messy ponytail. A sheriff's patrol car started keeping watch, parking in front of her house.
收到那封圣诞老人的信后，咪咪基本上停止了离开她家。她甚至不会去Zoom上参加她孩子的学校活动，以防其他家长认出她。当她不得不去杂货店时，她会隐姓埋名——戴口罩、帽子、乱糟糟的马尾辫。一辆治安官巡逻车开始盯着，停在她家门口。
She was getting threatening emails, angry phone calls in the middle of the night. I asked her if any of the threats she got were racist, given all the attacks against Asian-Americans this year. And she said no, just sexist. She was having trouble sleeping, bringing her laptop into bed every night. She gained 30 pounds and started taking blood pressure medication for the first time in her life.
她不断收到威胁邮件、半夜打来的愤怒电话。我问她所受到的威胁中是否有种族主义成分，鉴于今年针对亚裔美国人的攻击。她说没有，只是性别歧视。她睡眠困难，每晚把笔记本电脑带进卧室。她胖了30磅，并开始服用血压药物，这是她人生中第一次。
On bad days, she thought about quitting. She'd do what she calls retirement math, a trick she learned from another health official, to remind herself that she could quit any time and still get her pension.
在糟糕的日子里，她想过辞职。她会做她所谓的“退休数学”，这是她从另一位卫生官员那里学到的一个技巧，提醒自己可以随时辞职并依然能拿到养老金。
There were days I just felt like, I can't do this. I can't do it anymore. I can't get up tomorrow morning. I ex-- I was mentally, physically, emotionally exhausted. And then the way you know that your community feels about you, saying that you should be shot, you should all be shot, it just makes you want to cut out. That's why I thought the only way I can escape this is to just retire and be there more for my family.
有些日子我真的觉得，我做不到。我再也做不到了。我明天早上起不来。我的精神、身体、情感上都精疲力竭。然后那种你知道社区对你的看法，说你应该被枪杀，你们都应该被枪杀，这只会让你想逃避。这就是为什么我想，我能逃脱这一切的唯一方法就是退休，更多地陪伴我的家人。
Did you anyone in your family want you to quit, retire?
你的家人里有人希望你辞职、退休吗？
Yes, yes. My kids were scared. My oldest was like, "Mom, we can't do this. You can't do your job anymore. We have to go." I'm like, where are we going to go? What are we going to do? And you know, and it meant finding a different way to put my kids through college. And then we all decided, we will find a way to have a different kind of life, and it probably couldn't be here. We knew that for a fact. I mean, we talked about selling our home, and we all talked about the fact that if I have to do that, we're all OK with that.
有的，有的。我的孩子们很害怕。我的大女儿说：“妈妈，我们不能这样。你不能再做这份工作了。我们必须离开。”我说，我们要去哪里？我们要干什么？你知道，这意味着要找到另一种方式来供孩子们上大学。然后我们大家都决定，我们会找到一种过不同生活的方式，那很可能不能在这里。我们知道这是事实。我的意思是，我们讨论过卖掉我们的房子，我们也讨论过，如果我必须这样做，我们大家都觉得没问题。
In the battle between these willful public servants and the mob, Mimi and Gale never blinked. They've kept their misgivings to themselves. They've both toughed it out and stayed in their jobs. When the county furloughed employees, they worked through it to make sure vaccines got out. And they've gotten a lot done. It's clear they saved a lot of lives by locking down early.
在这些意志坚定的公务员与暴徒之间的较量中，咪咪和盖尔从未退缩。她们把不安藏在心里。她们俩都咬牙坚持下来，并留在了自己的工作岗位上。当县政府让员工停薪休假时，她们克服困难，确保疫苗分发出去。她们完成了很多工作。很明显，她们通过及早封锁挽救了许多生命。
But the thing they were trying so hard to prevent did eventually happen. In the fall, cases started to climb when the state loosened restrictions on restaurants and businesses and holiday gatherings began. Nursing homes in Santa Cruz got hit for the first time, causing the death rate in the county to spike. This was devastating to Gail and Mimi. They were seeing more deaths in a single day than they had in the first six months of the pandemic combined.
但她们如此努力试图防止的事情最终还是发生了。秋天，当州政府放宽了对餐馆和企业的限制，节日聚会开始时，病例开始攀升。圣克鲁斯的养老院首次受到冲击，导致该县的死亡率飙升。这对盖尔和咪咪来说是毁灭性的。她们在一天内看到的死亡人数比大流行前六个月加起来还要多。
There's this one press conference that Gail held last year that I still think about, because it feels indicative of where we are as a country right now. When Gail closed the beaches, lots of people ignored the order and went anyway. They threatened and harassed the officers who tried to enforce it. That weighed on Gail, especially after the deputy was killed. So she decided to reopen the beaches. She didn't think the security risk to the officers and to her was worth it anymore, especially if people weren't going to listen anyway.
去年盖尔举行了一次新闻发布会，我至今仍在思考，因为它感觉像是我们国家目前所处境地的缩影。当盖尔关闭海滩时，很多人无视命令还是去了。他们威胁并骚扰试图执行命令的官员。这给盖尔带来了沉重压力，特别是在那位代表被杀之后。所以她决定重新开放海滩。她觉得为了治安官和她自己承担的安全风险不再值得，特别是如果人们无论如何都不会听从的话。
And effective today at midnight, the beach closure will end. It's become impossible for law enforcement to continue to enforce that closure. People are not willing to be governed anymore, in that regard.
从今天午夜起，海滩关闭将结束。执法部门已无法继续执行该关闭令。人们在这一方面已不再愿意被治理了。
"People are not willing to be governed," at least not by officials who ask them to make sacrifices for their neighbors. And as a result, the officials, trying to govern us are quitting in droves. Since the beginning of the pandemic, nearly 250 public health officials working in communities all over the US have left their jobs, many because of threats and political pushback.
“人们已不再愿意被治理”，至少不愿意被那些要求他们为邻居做出牺牲的官员治理。结果就是，试图治理我们的官员正在大量辞职。自大流行开始以来，在美国各地社区工作的近250名公共卫生官员已经离职，许多是因为威胁和政治抵制。
Nearly one in six Americans now lives in a community that has lost its local health department leader during the pandemic, officials like Mimi and Gail. It's the largest exodus of health officials in US history.
现在，美国近六分之一的人口生活在社区中，那里的当地卫生部门负责人在大流行期间已经流失，就像咪咪和盖尔这样的官员。这是美国历史上最大规模的卫生官员离职潮。
Anna Maria Barry-Jester, she's a reporter from Kaiser Health News. More things happened, by the way, to Gail and Mimi than we can fit into our story, and it tells those things in the version that she wrote for Kaiser Health News. That's at khm.org.
安娜·玛丽亚·巴里-杰斯特，她是凯撒健康新闻的记者。顺便说一下，盖尔和咪咪身上发生的事情比我们能放入故事中的要多，她为凯撒健康新闻撰写的版本中讲述了这些内容。网址是khm.org。
[MUSIC - JOY AGAIN, "LOOKING OUT FOR YOU"]
[音乐 - JOY AGAIN, "LOOKING OUT FOR YOU"]
(SINGING) I guess should stop looking out for you like I always do. Start looking out for me, too. Instead of leaving me staring at my shoes.
（歌唱）我想我应该停止像我一直做的那样去关心你了。开始关心我自己。而不是让我盯着我的鞋子看。
Coming up, one bold man sits down with a bunch of Republicans who emphatically do not want the COVID vaccine and tries to figure out exactly what to say to them to get them to change their minds. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio, when our program continues.
接下来，一位大胆的人坐下来面对一群坚决不想接种新冠疫苗的共和党人，并试图弄清楚到底该对他们说什么才能让他们改变主意。那一集将在芝加哥公共广播电台一分钟后播出，我们的节目将继续。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today on our program, you can't get herd immunity until you deal with the herd and get enough of the moving together in the same direction, which has been difficult this past year in a way that it's never been during any epidemic in our history.
这是《这个美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。在今天的节目中，你无法获得群体免疫，除非你处理好这个群体，并让足够多的人朝着同一个方向共同努力，这在过去的一年里变得很困难，是我们历史上任何流行病中从未有过的。
Today, we have stories of people trying to steer the herd that is us. We've arrived at Act 2 of our program, Act 2, the Elephant in the Zoom.
今天，我们讲述人们试图引导这个“群体”的故事。我们来到了节目的第二幕，第二幕，房间里的大象。
So in the early part of the pandemic, it seemed like the hard part to ending this might be developing a vaccine. That part basically worked out. We got several in record time. But it turns out there's another hard part. Tens of millions of people in the United States are not sure they want to get the vaccine. One group that's particularly true of-- people who voted for President Trump.
所以在大流行初期，结束这一切的困难部分似乎是开发疫苗。这部分基本成功了。我们以创纪录的时间获得了几种疫苗。但事实证明，还有另一个困难部分。在美国，有数千万人不确定他们是否想接种疫苗。有一个群体尤其如此——投票给特朗普总统的人。
According to one poll, 40% of people who voted for President Trump said they did not plan to get the vaccine compared with 8% of people who voted for President Biden. David Kestenbaum has this next story about somebody trying to find something, some word, some fact, some story that can convince Trump Republicans to see this differently and get themselves vaccinated. Here's David.
根据一项民意调查，投票给特朗普总统的人中有40%表示他们不打算接种疫苗，而投票给拜登总统的人中这一比例为8%。大卫·克斯滕鲍姆（David Kestenbaum）带来了下一个故事，关于有人试图寻找某种东西，某个词，某个事实，某个故事，能够说服特朗普的共和党人以不同的视角看待这个问题并接种疫苗。请听大卫的报道。
The whole thing started with this public health institute in Maryland called the de Beaumont Foundation. They'd been noticing with alarm that not only were Trump voters reluctant to get the vaccine, they were stubbornly so. Other hesitant groups seemed to be coming around to getting the vaccine, but not the Trump voters. The numbers in surveys hadn't budged in months.
这一切始于马里兰州一个名为德博蒙基金会（de Beaumont Foundation）的公共卫生研究所。他们惊恐地注意到，特朗普的支持者不仅对接种疫苗感到犹豫，而且这种犹豫非常固执。其他犹豫的群体似乎正在开始接种疫苗，但特朗普的支持者却没有。调查数据几个月来一直没有变动。
The head of the foundation, Brian Castrucci, realized, basically, we need someone who speaks Republican.
基金会负责人布莱恩·卡斯特鲁奇（Brian Castrucci）意识到，基本上，我们需要一个懂“共和党语言”的人。
That was the group that we needed to reach out to, and we were doing a really poor job of it. And so go to the guy who knows that group. I mean, if I want really good bread, I go to a great baker. And so he was the great baker in this case.
那是我们需要接触的群体，而我们在这方面做得非常糟糕。所以去找那个了解这个群体的人。我的意思是，如果我想要非常好的面包，我就去找一位伟大的面包师。在这个案例中，他就是那位伟大的面包师。
The great baker? Frank Luntz, the pollster who is on TV and Fox News all the time. He'd been tracking and trying to understand the Republican electorate for decades.
伟大的面包师？弗兰克·伦茨（Frank Luntz），那个经常在电视和福克斯新闻（Fox News）上出现的民意测验专家。他几十年来一直在追踪和试图理解共和党的选民。
You know, Frank's an institution. He has changed people's votes. He's changed people's political ideologies. I think Frank knows how to use words!
你知道，弗兰克是一个机构。他改变了人们的投票。他改变了人们的政治意识形态。我认为弗兰克知道如何使用词语！
Brian was aware of the odd couple nature of this potential pairing. He says the public health community tends to be left of center. Frank Luntz was certainly good with words, but in a way some liberals hated him for. In the '90s, he was one of the people who worked on Newt Gingrich's Contract with America. He helped rebrand the estate tax as a death tax, and advised Republicans to use the words "climate change" instead of "global warming," because it sounded less alarming.
布莱恩意识到了这种潜在配对的怪异。他说公共卫生界倾向于中左翼。弗兰克·伦茨当然很擅长辞令，但以一种让一些自由派讨厌他的方式。在90年代，他是参与纽特·金里奇（Newt Gingrich）“与美国契约”（Contract with America）工作的人之一。他帮助将遗产税重塑为“死亡税”，并建议共和党人使用“气候变化”而不是“全球变暖”这两个词，因为前者听起来不那么令人担忧。
The phrase "government takeover of health care" for Obamacare? That came out of one of his focus groups. Basically, he was one of the people that had helped create the very polarization that was now one of the reasons people weren't getting vaccinated. But for Castrucci's purposes, what better person? So he tweeted at Luntz, kind of coyly. "Know someone who might be able to help?"
“政府接管医疗保健”这个词用来形容奥巴马医改？那是出自他的焦点小组。基本上，他就是帮助制造了那种极化现象的人之一，而这种极化现在是人们不接种疫苗的原因之一。但对于卡斯特鲁奇的目的来说，还有比这更好的人选吗？所以他在推特上以一种含蓄的方式发了推文：“认识什么可能帮得上忙的人吗？”
And I said, "Yeah, how about me?"
我说，“是的，我怎么样？”
This is Frank Luntz.
这是弗兰克·伦茨。
And they said, "Well, we figured you'd be too busy, but if you're interested, we would like you." Let me start again. By the way, I'm having-- I have good days and bad days, and this is a bad day, I will warn you.
他们说，“嗯，我们以为你太忙了，但如果你感兴趣，我们想要你。”让我重新开始。顺便说一下，我正在经历——我有好日子也有坏日子，今天是坏日子，我先提醒你。
Frank had a stroke a year ago in January, which is actually one of the reasons he wanted to work on this. The experience made him really angry with all the people who weren't getting vaccinated. He says the stroke was this thing he probably could have prevented if he'd done what the doctor said. But he didn't take care of himself, didn't take his medication. And now, seeing people do some version of that, not protecting themselves by getting the vaccine, endangering themselves and others, it was driving him crazy. Like, you people are healthy. You don't realize what you have. The stroke affected his left arm and his speech.
弗兰克一年前在一月患了中风，这实际上是他想从事这项工作的原因之一。这段经历让他对所有那些没有接种疫苗的人感到非常愤怒。他说，如果他听从医生的建议，中风可能是他本可以预防的。但他没有照顾好自己，没有按时服药。现在，看到人们做着某种类似的事情，没有通过接种疫苗来保护自己，危及自己和他人，这让他感到疯狂。就像，你们这些人很健康。你们没有意识到你们拥有什么。中风影响了他的左臂和言语。
I have to think of how I enunciate. I have to fight-- I used to be confident in doing interviews like this. They were very easy for me. It was very simple. And it's not simple anymore. I realize when I sit, I sit with this hand clenched, and it doesn't look right. Even when I talk on TV, I tend to talk with my hands now in my pockets, because I don't want people to see that the hand doesn't work right.
我必须思考我如何发音。我必须战斗——我过去对做这样的采访充满信心。它们对我来说非常容易。这非常简单。但现在不再简单了。我意识到当我坐着时，我紧握着这只手，看起来不对劲。即使我在电视上交谈，我现在也倾向于把手放在口袋里，因为我不想让人看到那只手工作不正常。
So he was in a different spot than usual when the de Beaumont Foundation reached out to him. Frank told the foundation what he'd like to do-- get together a group of Trump Republicans who were reluctant to get the vaccine, a focus group like Frank had done so many times. But he wouldn't just ask them their opinions. He set out as a goal in an hour and a half, he was going to try to change their minds, convince them to get the vaccine.
所以当德博蒙基金会联系他时，他处于一个不同于往常的位置。弗兰克告诉基金会他想做什么——召集一组对接种疫苗犹豫不决的特朗普共和党人，就像弗兰克过去多次做的那样做一个焦点小组。但他不会只问他们的观点。他设定的目标是在一个半小时内，他要试着改变他们的主意，说服他们接种疫苗。
He figured, if he could do that, he'd learn how to do it for the millions of other Trump Republicans out there. Frank had a bit of a strategy, but he says these things involve a lot of improvisation. He doesn't write questions out in advance. He runs his focus groups in a state of kind of hyper-awareness. He says the main thing he tries to do is really listen to what people are saying, but also the words they're using, the way they're talking.
他认为，如果他能做到这一点，他就能学会如何为那里的数百万其他特朗普共和党人做到这一点。弗兰克有一点策略，但他表示这些事情需要大量的即兴发挥。他不预先写好问题。他在一种高度意识的状态下进行他的焦点小组。他说他试图做的主要事情是真正倾听人们在说什么，还有他们使用的词语，他们交谈的方式。
And at the same time he's listening, he's also trying to read the reactions of everyone in the room, whether they're looking up or down or fidgeting. He thinks he's done thousands of these things over his career. He once told a reporter, I don't know shit about anything with the exception of what the American people think.
同时在他倾听的过程中，他也试图阅读房间里每个人的反应，无论他们是在向上看还是向下看，还是坐立不安。他认为他职业生涯中已经做了数千次这样的事情。他曾经告诉一位记者，除了美国人民的想法，我对任何事情一无所知。
The experiment took place over Zoom on a Saturday afternoon last month. There were 20 people he was going to try to sway, mostly white, middle-aged, everyone in their little boxes on the screen, a bookshelf or a desk or a plant in the background. Below each person-- first names and state. Debbie from Georgia, Doug from California, Lisa from Ohio, Patrick from Tennessee, all recruited by Frank's team. Frank was very clear at the start about how they'd been selected.
这项实验发生在上个月的一个周六下午，通过Zoom进行。他要试图影响的有20个人，主要是白人、中年人，每个人都在屏幕上的小方框里，背景是一个书架、一张桌子或一棵植物。每个人名字下方——名字和州。来自乔治亚州的黛比（Debbie），来自加州的道格（Doug），来自俄亥俄州的丽莎（Lisa），来自田纳西州的帕特里克（Patrick），所有都是由弗兰克的团队招募的。弗兰克在开始时非常清楚他们是如何被挑选出来的。
You all have two things in common-- you all voted for Donald Trump in 2020, and you all expressed at least some hesitation about getting the COVID vaccine. So you represent about 30 million people.
你们所有人有两个共同点——你们都在2020年投票给唐纳德·特朗普，并且你们所有人都表示对接种新冠疫苗至少有一些犹豫。所以你们代表了大约3000万人。
But as soon as he got into it, Frank suspected there was a problem. The participants had said when they were recruited that there was some chance they would get the vaccine. But a lot of them seemed like they might actually be firm no's. He wondered if they had said they were maybes just because they didn't want to come off like anti-vaxxers. Frank says that's how they feel they get portrayed in the press. If they weren't maybes but were really no's, this was not going to work.
但当他刚开始进入时，弗兰克怀疑出了问题。参与者在被招募时曾表示他们接种疫苗的可能性很大。但他们中的许多人看起来好像可能确实是坚定地拒绝。他怀疑他们说可能是因为他们不想看起来像反疫苗者。弗兰克说这就是他们觉得自己在媒体中被描绘的方式。如果他们不是“可能”而是真正地拒绝，这行不通。
Explain to me when you hear the word COVID, COVID-19, what word or phrase comes to mind?
向我解释一下，当你听到“新冠”（COVID）、“新冠-19”（COVID-19）这个词时，脑子里会浮现出什么词或短语？
Controversy.
争议。
Sue?
苏（Sue）？
Manipulation.
操纵。
David.
大卫。
Government manipulation.
政府操纵。
Marie.
玛丽（Marie）。
I would call it a hyped-up version of the flu.
我会称之为流感的炒作版本。
It was alarming, he said. He'd asked them about a disease, and their answers were all about politics. Here they are on Tony Fauci, the White House's chief medical advisor.
他说，这很令人警觉。他问的是一种疾病，而他们的回答全都是关于政治的。这是他们谈论托尼·福奇（Tony Fauci），白宫首席医学顾问时的样子。
Wishy-washy.
优柔寡断。
Liar.
骗子。
Puppet.
傀儡。
Inconsistent.
不连贯。
He asked them about the thing he was hoping to sway them on, the vaccine.
他问了他们关于他希望影响他们的事情，即疫苗。
Adam, what do you think of first?
亚当（Adam），你首先想到的是什么？
A miracle, albeit suspicious.
一个奇迹，尽管很可疑。
Patrick?
帕特里克？
Rushed.
草率。
Diane from Ohio.
来自俄亥俄州的黛安（Diane）。
Unproven.
未经验证。
Michael from Oklahoma.
来自俄克拉荷马州的迈克尔（Michael）。
Don't hold my freedom hostage.
别拿我的自由做人质。
And Jen from Iowa.
还有来自爱荷华州的珍（Jen）。
Untrustworthy.
不可信。
Oh, my god.
天哪。
To be clear, COVID is much more deadly than the flu, and the vaccine has gone through extensive testing. Maybe the most worrying moment for Frank, a woman named Jen just kind of let drop this thing. She said her husband had almost died from COVID.
需要明确的是，新冠病毒比流感致命得多，而且疫苗已经经过了广泛的测试。也许对弗兰克来说最担心的时刻是，一个名叫珍的女人只是随口说出了这件事。她说她的丈夫差点死于新冠。
Yeah, he was in intensive care for three weeks.
是的，他在重症监护室呆了三个星期。
So then why doesn't that lead you to get a vaccine as soon as possible?
那为什么这没能让你尽快去接种疫苗呢？
Because I believe that our bodies naturally can fight off infections, although he did need assistance for his to end or to get better. I also understand people's perspective on how they believe in the vaccine, and it's totally the only way out of this deal. I respect that. But for us personally, I don't know. I really am highly undoubtful that we'll ever get vaccinated for this, even though it almost killed him.
因为我相信我们的身体自然可以抵抗感染，尽管他确实需要辅助才能好转。我也理解人们关于他们如何相信疫苗的观点，这是摆脱这个局面的唯一途径。我尊重这一点。但就我们个人而言，我不知道。我真的高度怀疑我们是否会因为这个而接种疫苗，即使它差点杀了他。
I want to say right here, I wasn't allowed to talk to any of the participants. Which I wanted to do. I don't want them to come across as soundbite clichés. They were willing to put themselves out there, and they spoke pretty candidly. So I want to take a minute here to try to give you a sense for some of the things they said over the session, about why they were reluctant to get the vaccine.
我想在这里说一句，我不被允许与任何参与者交谈。但我很想这么做。我不希望他们被当作声音片段里的陈词滥调。他们愿意公开自己，而且他们说得非常坦诚。所以我在这里想花点时间试图让你了解他们在会议中提到的一些关于他们为什么对接种疫苗犹豫不决的原因。
Lots of people said they were worried about the long-term side effects from the vaccine. Lauren, a teacher in New Jersey, said she just didn't feel comfortable with the idea of something so new being injected into her body. An older man said, my fear of the vaccine is more than my fear of getting the illness.
很多人说他们担心疫苗的长期副作用。新泽西州的一名老师劳伦（Lauren）说，她只是对把某种如此新的东西注入她体内的想法感到不舒服。一位老先生说，我对疫苗的恐惧超过了我对患病的恐惧。
And just to say, the concern about side effects, that's one lots of hesitant groups have. It was the top reason in a survey of Black Americans and in a survey of people in six Latin American countries. One person in the focus group, but only one, cited concerns he'd heard from a couple of anti-vax doctors.
顺便说一下，对副作用的担忧，是许多犹豫群体都有的。这是一项针对美国黑人的调查和一项针对六个拉丁美洲国家人们的调查中提到的首要原因。焦点小组中的一个人（只有一个）提到了他从几个反疫苗医生那里听到的担忧。
They'd clearly heard mainstream health messages about the vaccine. They'd encountered that stuff. But it was mixed in with so many other things they disagreed with. They thought the press didn't always put things in proper perspective when covering the pandemic. Here's Brian from Texas.
他们显然听说过主流的疫苗信息。他们遇到过那些东西。但它与他们不同意的许多其他事情混在了一起。他们认为媒体在报道大流行时并不总是把事情放在适当的视角下。这是来自德克萨斯州的布莱恩（Brian）。
The virus is real, but everybody is ignoring the actual facts of the virus, the great media. If you're over 65 or if you're fat, you're much more likely to get the virus horribly and possibly die from it.
病毒是真的，但每个人都忽略了病毒的实际事实，伟大的媒体。如果你超过65岁或者如果你很胖，你更有可能非常严重地感染病毒并可能因此死亡。
But if you're not, he says, you're at way less risk of dying.
但如果不是这样，他说，你死亡的风险要小得多。
And they totally ignored that. The media totally feeds on that and wants to sell that. And everybody that don't think, they just panic. And people that you thought were normally, sane, intelligent people were totally like, "Oh my god, I'm going to die from this virus."
而他们完全忽略了这一点。媒体完全利用这一点并想要推销它。那些没有思考的人，他们只是恐慌。而那些你认为平时正常、理智、聪明的人，完全就像是，“天哪，我要死于这种病毒了。”
At some point, Frank showed everyone a PSA by the Ad Council that totally bombed, featured former presidents, including George W. Bush but not President Trump, though even that wouldn't have helped.
在某个时刻，弗兰克给每个人看了广告委员会（Ad Council）的一段完全失败的PSA，里面有包括乔治·W·布什在内的前总统，但没有特朗普总统，尽管即使那样也不会有帮助。
Not a bit.
一点都没有。
Not a whole lot.
没太多。
At the end, the ad urged people to, quote, "do their part." Erin, who lives in Florida, said when people make that kind of argument, it bugs her.
最后，广告敦促人们，引用名言，“尽自己的一份力量”。住在佛罗里达州的艾琳（Erin）说，当人们提出那种论点时，这让她很烦。
Condescending. "We're all in this together." People are exhausted of that.
屈尊俯就。“我们都在一起。”人们对那个已经精疲力竭了。
Absolutely.
当然。
Because we're not. We're not.
因为我们不在。我们不在。
Because we haven't been in it all together.
因为我们没有在一起。
Their kids have gone to private school. We're not all in this together. And I hate when they act like we have been, because we haven't.
他们的孩子去了私立学校。我们不是都在一起。我讨厌他们表现得好像我们一直在一起一样，因为我们没有。
And finally, underlying all this, politics. Many said they felt like Democrats had exaggerated COVID so they could use it to defeat President Trump. Some wondered if the drug companies had delayed releasing the vaccine results until after the election. The head of Pfizer has said he would never do that. I asked Frank what he thought the problem would be that he'd have to overcome? "I thought the problem was going to be everything," he said. That turned out to be right.
最后，这一切的根本原因是政治。许多人说他们觉得民主党人夸大了新冠病毒，这样他们就可以利用它来击败特朗普总统。有些人想知道药企是否推迟了公布疫苗结果直到选举之后。辉瑞的负责人说他永远不会那样做。我问弗兰克他认为他必须克服的问题会是什么？他说：“我以为问题会是所有一切。”结果证明是对的。
About a half hour in, Frank switched from listening to actually trying to persuade them. Here he did have a plan. He'd lined up a bunch of high profile guests who were just going to drop into the Zoom meeting. Frank put them in a particular order. He wanted the first person to be someone who really knew about the vaccine in detail. Though his choice for this seemed like maybe an odd one, Dr. Tom Frieden, the head of the CDC under Obama. Frank didn't introduce him that way.
大约半小时后，弗兰克从倾听转向了真正试图说服他们。在这里他确实有一个计划。他安排了一群高调的嘉宾，他们只是会跳进Zoom会议中。弗兰克把他们按特定的顺序排列。他希望第一个人是一个真正详细了解疫苗的人。尽管他对此的选择看起来可能有点奇怪，汤姆·弗里登（Tom Frieden）医生，奥巴马时期的CDC主任。弗兰克没有那样介绍他。
Now, Tom is the most distinguished leader of the CDC in modern history. He will deny that introduction, but this guy knows his stuff.
现在，汤姆是现代历史上最杰出的CDC领导人。他会否认这个介绍，但这个家伙很懂行。
Frieden gave a pretty standard public health spiel.
弗里登发表了一套非常标准的公共卫生说辞。
Now, if you ask me, how can you know this isn't going to have a problem 10 years down the line, I don't. I can't tell you with certainty. But I can explain how the vaccine works.
现在，如果你问我，你怎么知道10年后这不会出问题，我不知道。我不能确定地告诉你。但我可以解释疫苗是如何工作的。
Frank went around for a reaction, to see how it had gone.
弗兰克四处询问反应，看看情况如何。
All true. Heard the science before, but it doesn't line up with what the response to the virus was on a federal level and a state level.
全都是真的。以前听过科学，但它与联邦和州层面的病毒应对措施不一致。
And therefore?
所以呢？
I'm not going to take a vaccine.
我不打算接种疫苗。
At some point during this whole thing, you can see Frank look down.
在这一切过程中的某个时刻，你可以看到弗兰克低下了头。
I got my head in my hand. They can see me, so I had to be really careful. But I know that a couple moments, I went down, and I was doing texts at the time. And I actually said, "I'm done. This is going to fail."
我把头埋在手里。他们能看见我，所以我必须非常小心。但我知道有几个时刻，我低下了头，当时我在发短信。我实际上说，“我完了。这会失败。”
That's really what was going through your head.
那真的是你脑子里在想的事情吗？
That's half. OK, yeah. Fuck. I don't want to fail.
是一半。好的，是的。该死。我不想失败。
Yeah.
是的。
The head of the de Beaumont Foundation that was paying for this, Brian Castrucci, felt nauseous at this point. He told me he actually pulled over a trash can. It seemed like nothing was going to work. Frank had reinforcements. Next up were the politicians, all supporters of President Trump, who presumably these voters might like and listen to. Frank said when he reached out to them, they were game, but were like, can you give us some talking points? Frank told them to just be themselves. The whole point was to just try stuff and see what might work.
为此买单的德博蒙基金会负责人布莱恩·卡斯特鲁奇在这一点上感到恶心。他告诉我他实际上把车停在了垃圾桶旁。看起来什么都不会奏效。弗兰克有增援部队。接下来是政治家们，全是特朗普总统的支持者，假设这些选民可能喜欢并听他们的。弗兰克说当他联系他们时，他们很愿意，但就像，你能给我们提供一些谈话要点吗？弗兰克告诉他们做自己就行。重点就是试一试，看看什么可能奏效。
First up was Senator Bill Cassidy from Louisiana, who's also a doctor. He offered a seatbelt analogy.
第一个是来自路易斯安那州的参议员比尔·卡西迪（Bill Cassidy），他也是一名医生。他提出了一个安全带类比。
And so I compare this to wearing a seatbelt. You don't think you're going to get in a wreck, but you're certainly glad if you happen to get in a wreck, that you're wearing the seatbelt.
所以我把它比作系安全带。你并不认为你会发生事故，但如果你碰巧发生了事故，你肯定会很高兴自己系了安全带。
Then Kevin McCarthy joined the Zoom, the top Republican in the House of Representatives.
然后凯文·麦卡锡（Kevin McCarthy）加入了Zoom，他是众议院中共和党的最高领导人。
President Trump got the vaccine. He got COVID, but he also understood--
特朗普总统接种了疫苗。他得了新冠，但他同时也理解——
Brad Wenstrup, a congressman and doctor, also tried. And pieces of what they said did seem to resonate and loosen things up, but it didn't feel like anyone had really moved. Frank said he thought this part would have gone better. One of the surprising takeaways from the session was just how ineffective messages about the vaccine are when they're coming from politicians.
布拉德·温斯特鲁普（Brad Wenstrup），一名国会议员和医生，也尝试了。他们说的话片段似乎确实产生了共鸣并放松了一些东西，但感觉没有人真的被触动。弗兰克说他以为这一部分会进行得更好。从会议中得出的令人惊讶的要点之一是，当政治家传达关于疫苗的信息时，信息是多么无效。
I've watched the recording of this whole focus group several times, trying to figure out the moment things started to shift, and why. Something happened just after this that took Frank by surprise. Frank went back to Tom Frieden, who had run the CDC for so long. He's a physician, not a politician. Frank says there's an order in which things need to be communicated to move someone. And he thought now they were ready for facts.
我看了几次这个完整焦点小组的录像，试图找出事情开始转变的时刻，以及原因。这之后发生了一些让弗兰克感到惊讶的事情。弗兰克回到了汤姆·弗里登身边，他管理CDC那么久。他是一名医生，不是政治家。弗兰克说有一个传达信息的顺序需要遵循才能触动某人。他认为现在他们已经准备好接收事实了。
One woman in the group said basically emotions work for Democrats, we want facts. It came up a bunch.
小组中的一位女性基本上说情感对民主党人有效，我们需要事实。这提到了好几次。
Doug says he wants facts. Let's go.
道格说他想要事实。开始吧。
Frieden had been listening, and it was like he'd been collecting all the concerns and questions he'd been hearing and lining up responses in his head. And in one minute, he just spit out these five things he wanted everyone to know as clearly as he could.
弗里登一直在倾听，这就像他一直在收集他听到的担忧和问题，并在脑海中排列回应。在一分钟内，他就像能多清楚就多清楚地吐出了这五件他想让每个人都知道的事情。
One, if you get infected with the virus, it will go all over your body and stay there for at least a week and be much more likely to cause you long-term problems than the vaccine. Two, if you get the vaccine, it will prime your immune system, but then the vaccine is gone. It will not be with you anymore. Three, more than 95% of the doctors who have been offered this vaccine have gotten it as soon as they can. Four, the more we vaccinate, the faster we can get back to growing our economy and getting jobs. And five, if people get vaccinated, we're going to save at least 100,000 lives of Americans who would otherwise be killed by COVID.
第一，如果你感染了病毒，它会遍布你全身并至少停留一周，比疫苗更容易导致你的长期问题。第二，如果你接种了疫苗，它会激活你的免疫系统，然后疫苗就消失了。它不会再和你在一起了。第三，超过95%被邀请接种这种疫苗的医生都在他们能接种时就接种了。第四，我们接种的人越多，我们就能越快回到经济增长和获得就业的状态。第五，如果人们接种了疫苗，我们将至少挽救10万名美国人的生命，否则他们会被新冠病毒夺走。
OK, I want to show of hands. How many of you would say that those five facts are impactful to you?
好的，我想举手表决。你们中有多少人会说那五个事实对你有冲击力？
Impactful. Yeah.
有冲击力。是的。
Wow. Wow, that's a lot of you.
哇。哇，你们很多人。
Frank says in his experience, there's kind of two things you need to move someone. Two components to a person making a decision. They're the facts, which they now had. The other one is actually the thing they seem skeptical about, emotion. And that is what the last person to speak delivered.
弗兰克说根据他的经验，要触动某人有两种东西。一个人做决定有两个组成部分。一个是事实，他们现在已经有了。另一个实际上是他们似乎怀疑的东西，情感。而这正是最后一位发言的人传达的东西。
This last guest Frank didn't know what he was going to say exactly, but he put him last intentionally-- former New Jersey Governor Chris Christie. Christie didn't give a speech. He didn't try to persuade them to get the vaccine. He just kind of said, here's what happened to me. Maybe you'll find it useful. I'm going to play you a bunch of what he said.
这位最后一位嘉宾，弗兰克不知道他会说什么确切内容，但他故意把他排在最后——前新泽西州州长克里斯·克里斯蒂（Chris Christie）。克里斯蒂没有发表演讲。他没有试图说服他们接种疫苗。他只是说，这就是发生在我身上的事情。也许你会觉得它有用。我要为你播放一段他说的内容。
Well, I think what I'd say to you is talk about three different experiences that I've had with COVID. And the point I want to try to make is how random it is. And as Patrick's saying, he had a cold for three days and didn't really feel all that badly. You all know how I got it. I went into what was supposed to be the safest place in America, the White House.
好吧，我想我要对你们说的是谈谈我经历过的关于新冠的三种不同体验。我想努力表达的观点是它是多么随机。正如帕特里克所说，他感冒了三天，并没有真的感到那么糟糕。你们都知道我得病的情况。我走进了本应该是美国最安全的地方，白宫。
And I went, and I got tested every day as I walked in. I'm brought to the Eisenhower Building, swabbed, had to wait there for the test results to come back. If it came back negative, which they did every day that I was there, I could then go into the West Wing.
我进去了，我每天走进去时都会接受检测。我被带到艾森豪威尔大楼，擦拭，必须在那里等测试结果出来。如果结果呈阴性，就像我在那里的每一天一样，我就可以进入西翼。
Christie was the first person to tell an actual story. I hadn't heard all the details before. This all happened when he was helping prep the first presidential debate.
克里斯蒂是第一个讲述真实故事的人。我之前没有听过所有的细节。这一切发生在他帮助筹备第一次总统辩论时。
And there were seven people in the Map Room at the White House for about 16 hours over four days together. And of those seven people, six of them got COVID. In the place that was the safest, most tested place in America.
在白宫地图室里，有七个人在一起待了大约四天，共16个小时。那七个人中，有六个人得了新冠。在那个美国最安全、检测最严格的地方。
I got it, and Hope Hicks got it, and Kellyanne Conway got it, and the president got it. Bill Stepien got it. And Stephen Miller. All of us got it. All of us got it at a bit of a different time. And all of us got it at a bit of a different severity. And by randomness, I mean, I was the sickest of everybody, and had the longest hospitalization.
我得了，霍普·希克斯（Hope Hicks）得了，凯莉安·康威（Kellyanne Conway）得了，总统得了。比尔·斯蒂平（Bill Stepien）得了。还有斯蒂芬·米勒（Stephen Miller）。我们所有人都得了。我们所有人都得了，时间点略有不同。而且我们所有人的严重程度也略有不同。通过随机性，我的意思是，我是所有人中最严重的，住院时间最长。
The next sickest person was the president. But the next sickest person after that was Hope Hicks, who was the youngest and most fit person in that room. Someone who, you know, ran four to five miles every day, in her early 30s, and was the most fit. She was out of it for a good 10 days, and never had to be hospitalized. But called me during it, and told me it was the sickest she'd ever been.
下一个最严重的是总统。但在那之后下一个最严重的是霍普·希克斯，她是那个房间里最年轻、身体最健康的人。一个你知道，每天跑四到五英里，30出头，身体最健康的人。她病了整整10天，从不需要住院。但在生病期间给我打电话，告诉我这是她经历过的最严重的病。
Two other people in my family, a 64-year-old cousin, who was a smoker. And so she had some potential problem, got it. Felt OK in the beginning, wound up hospitalized. Her husband, 63, no preexisting conditions, great shape. In fact, was still working every day as an active longshoreman on the docks in New Jersey. He got sick as well. Caught it presumably from his wife. They both wound up being hospitalized. And two weeks ago, they both passed away.
我家人中的另外两人，一个64岁的表亲，是个吸烟者。所以她有一些潜在问题，得了病。开始时感觉还好，最后住院了。她的丈夫，63岁，没有既往症，身材很好。事实上，作为新泽西码头上的一名活跃码头工人，他每天仍在工作。他也病了。大概是从他妻子那里传染的。他们两个最终都住院了。两周前，他们俩都去世了。
It wasn't hard to read the room. Everyone was paying attention. One person said, "I wasn't expecting him to say that, that they had passed away." Two were surprised to hear that Hope Hicks ran four miles a day and had still gotten so sick. Christie told them he sympathized with their skepticism about politicians on this issue. Like the presidents in that vaccine PSA, "Listen," he said. "I know all those people. I've met all those people. I'm not asking them whether I should take the vaccine."
读懂这个房间并不难。每个人都在注意听。一个人说，“我没料到他会那么说，他们已经去世了。”两个人对听说霍普·希克斯每天跑四英里仍然病得那么重感到惊讶。克里斯蒂告诉他们，他同情他们在这个问题上对政治家的怀疑。就像疫苗PSA中的那些总统一样，“听着，”他说，“我认识所有那些人。我见过所有那些人。我不是在问他们我是否应该接种疫苗。”
--politics. Politicians screw up almost everything we touch. We really do.
——政治。政治家搞砸了我们触碰的所有东西。我们确实搞砸了。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
We just do.
我们就是这样。
That's the understatement of the century.
那是本世纪最轻描淡写的陈述。
Right? We just do. And so I understand why people are skeptical. But you know what? The scientists and the doctors are saying this is the right thing to do. So since I don't know anything about medicine, I'm going to follow their advice.
对吧？我们就是这样。所以我理解为什么人们怀疑。但你知道吗？科学家和医生说这是正确的做法。既然我对医学一无所知，我就会听从他们的建议。
The session ran long, to almost 2 and 1/2 hours. And maybe it was the accumulation of everything they had heard, but suddenly after Chris Christie, it was like they were in a different world. This is Matthew, who lives in Michigan. He said he'd heard a lot of this stuff before, but somehow it was landing differently. At the beginning, he had been 90% against getting the vaccine. He'd completely flipped.
会议开得很长，将近2个半小时。也许是因为他们听到的所有东西积累在一起，但在克里斯蒂之后，突然间好像他们进入了一个不同的世界。这是住密歇根州的马修（Matthew）。他说他以前听过很多这种东西，但不知怎的，它落地时的感觉不同了。开始时，他曾有90%反对接种疫苗。他完全改变了看法。
My biggest thing is like, these are great-- this is great information. It's just, how do we get this information out to-- to the public, especially us, you know, Trump voters and that the masses of us are going to believe it? And I don't think we're going to move everyone, but how do we get it out there?
我最大的一点是，这些都很棒——这些是伟大的信息。只是，我们如何把这些信息传达给公众，特别是我们，你知道，特朗普的支持者，以及我们大众会相信它？我不认为我们会触动每个人，但我们如何把它传播出去？
Here's Sue, who lives in Iowa.
这是住在爱荷华州的苏（Sue）。
I think what I've learned is, I probably need to separate my reaction to the government involvement in this, and look at just the science. I'm a pharmacist. I used to work for Merck. I know all their vaccines are good products. I trust them. What I don't trust is the government telling me what I need to do when they haven't led us down the right road, in my view, to this day. So if I can set the government aside and just look at the science and think about it from a medical standpoint, I think I'm OK.
我想我学到的是，我可能需要把我对政府参与此事的反应分开，只看科学。我是一名药剂师。我过去为默克公司（Merck）工作。我知道他们所有的疫苗都是好产品。我相信他们。我不相信的是当政府在我的观点中还没引导我们走上正确的道路时告诉我要做什么。所以如果我可以把政府放在一边，只看科学并从医学角度考虑它，我想我是可以接受的。
Frank went around to everyone to see where they started and where they ended up, and they had all moved.
弗兰克四处询问每个人开始时的情况以及他们最终的情况，他们都改变了。
So I think my opinion has changed. Before I would have said I was in the middle of the fence on whether or not I would get the vaccination. And now, I'm leaning a little more towards getting the vaccination. So I probably went from a 5 out of 10 to maybe a 7 out of 10.
所以我认为我的观点改变了。之前我会说我在要不要接种疫苗的问题上处于中间围栏上。而现在，我更倾向于接种疫苗。所以我可能从10分中的5分变成了大概7分。
I would say I was probably 80% against when this started today. Now I'm probably 50-50-ish.
我会说我开始的时候大概80%反对。现在我大概是50/50左右。
Yeah, when I came in, I was 50-50. And I still want to know what's in it. I still want to find-- I want to know what's in the vaccine. I don't want-- I want to know what the ingredients are. But I'm probably about 80, 85% sure that I will get the vaccine.
是的，当我进来时，我是50/50。我仍然想知道里面有什么。我仍然想发现——我想知道疫苗的成分。我不想——我想知道成分是什么。但我大概80、85%确定我会接种疫苗。
I was unlikely to get it unless I was forced to, to start with. So maybe 2 out of 10. And now I'm probably 9 out of 10 going to get it.
一开始我不太可能接种，除非被强迫。所以可能是10分里的2分。而现在我大概有10分里的9分会接种它。
Here's what Frank was thinking right then.
这是弗兰克当时的想法。
"Fuck, yeah." I mean, that's literally-- those were the two words I thought to myself.
“该死，是的。”我的意思是，那就是字面意思——那是我对自己想的两个词。
So a skeptic would say, OK, you've demonstrated-- what you've demonstrated here in this focus group is that if you get 20 people in Zoom with the former head of the CDC, a former governor, a senator, the leader of the Republicans in the House and another representative, then yes, you can move them, and to where they say they'll consider it. But you can't repeat that with millions of people.
所以一个怀疑者会说，好吧，你在这里证明的是——你在焦点小组中展示的是，如果你让20个人通过Zoom与前CDC主任、前州长、参议员、众议院共和党领导人和另一位代表在一起，那么是的，你可以影响他们，达到他们说会考虑的程度。但你不能对数百万人重复这一点。
That's the challenge that we have.
这是我们面临的挑战。
There are plenty of reasons to be skeptical about focus groups. There are movies that test well in focus groups but bomb at the box office. And Frank hasn't followed up to see if any of the people have actually gotten the vaccine, though he says he will. I asked him about that moment at the end. Wasn't it possible people were just being swayed by the person who'd gone before them, that he was getting some form of groupthink and not actual change? He didn't think so, not with this group.
有充分的理由怀疑焦点小组。有些电影在焦点小组测试得很好，但在票房上却失败了。弗兰克还没有跟进看是否有人真正接种了疫苗，尽管他说他会。我问他关于最后那个时刻。人们是不是只是被之前发言的人影响了，他是不是陷入了某种群体思维而不是真正的改变？他不这么认为，这个小组不会。
These people have no problem speaking out. They have no problem saying no. And they did so all through the first half or 2/3 of the group. They rejected everything.
这些人对于说出来没有任何问题。他们对于说“不”没有任何问题。他们在小组的前半部分或三分之二部分一直这样做。他们拒绝了一切。
Yeah, but at the end, they're all using kind of similar language. I was talking to someone about it. They're like, you know, that's actually a powerful thing, if that's what's going on there. Because that is how things really get going in the real world is, like, you know people around you who have gotten the vaccine. And so it becomes normal, and you think maybe I'll get it, too.
是的，但在最后，他们都在使用相似的语言。我和某人谈论过它。他们就像，你知道，如果那是发生的事情，那实际上是一件强大的事情。因为那确实是事情在现实世界中真正开始的方式，你知道，你认识周围接种了疫苗的人。所以它变得正常了，你会想也许我也会接种。
Absolutely. But they're trying to decide who to listen to.
当然。但他们试图决定听谁的。
Here's what Frank said he learned from the whole thing. The basic facts really did matter, but they needed to be presented in the right way. One participant put it like this. "We want to be educated, not indoctrinated." And also, you need the right person to deliver the facts. And Frank thinks the most persuasive messenger is probably people's own doctors.
这是弗兰克说他从整个事情中学到的。基本事实确实很重要，但它们需要以正确的方式呈现。一位参与者这样表达。“我们要受教育，而不是被洗脑。”而且，你还需要正确的人来传达事实。弗兰克认为最有说服力的传达者可能是人们自己的医生。
I talked to a researcher who studies vaccine hesitancy, who totally agreed about this. Getting a vaccine, some foreign thing injected into your body, that's a medical decision. And for a lot of people, the person they trust for that isn't the president, or some celebrity, or the TV news. It's their doctor, who they've chosen, who, if you're over a certain age, you've probably been through some real stuff with. They know the facts, and they're a person you might have an emotional connection to.
我和一位研究疫苗犹豫不决的研究员谈过，他完全同意这一点。接种疫苗，某种被注入你体内的外来东西，那是一个医疗决定。对很多人来说，他们对此信任的人不是总统，也不是什么名人，也不是电视新闻。而是他们的医生，他们选择的医生，如果你超过一定年龄，你可能已经和他们一起经历了一些真正的事情。他们知道事实，他们是一个你可能与其有情感联系的人。
Again, those two ingredients-- facts and emotion. Frank's dream is that doctors will reach out to their patients, maybe record a video of themselves on their laptop or phone, and send it out.
同样，那两个成分——事实和情感。弗兰克的梦想是医生会联系他们的病人，也许在他们的笔记本电脑或手机上录制一段视频，然后发送出去。
There is an ad in the works, based on this focus group. It'll feature a celebrity who plays a doctor on TV, like Gray's Anatomy or The Good Doctor, but appearing with their own actual doctor, talking about the vaccine. Which, who knows, this group seems skeptical of any kind of preproduced persuasion.
有一个基于这个焦点小组的广告正在筹备中。它将以一位在电视上扮演医生的名人，比如《实习医生格蕾》（Gray's Anatomy）或《良医》（The Good Doctor），但与他们自己实际的医生一起出现，谈论疫苗。谁知道呢，这个群体似乎对任何种类的预制说服都很怀疑。
For me, maybe the most remarkable thing about this little experiment is the simple fact of how it ended up. Over two hours, some thing or combination of things did seem to move people. It really could have failed, but it didn't. At the end, there was one final person to talk, who hadn't really said a lot in the focus group up to this point. It was Frank, who talked about the moment he did the thing that he was hoping they will all do.
对我来说，这个小实验最引人注目的也许是它如何结束的简单事实。在两个小时内，某种东西或东西的组合确实似乎触动了人们。它本来可能失败，但它没有。在最后，还有最后一个人要发言，他在焦点小组中到目前为止并没有说太多话。那是弗兰克，他谈到了他做那件他希望他们所有人都能做的事情的那一刻。
When they put that needle in my arm for the first vaccine, I really felt like this was the pain of life. And I am so grateful to our medical professionals, and so grateful to our pharmaceutical companies and American ingenuity. And I wish that you all could feel what I felt. Because this, to me, was the ultimate definition of freedom. It's the ultimate definition of liberty. It's the ultimate definition of the country that I'm so lucky to be born here.
当他们把那根针刺进我的手臂接种第一剂疫苗时，我真的觉得这就是生命的痛楚。我非常感谢我们的医疗专业人员，非常感谢我们的制药公司和美国的独创性。我希望你们所有人都能感受到我的感受。因为对我来说，这就是自由的终极定义。它是自由的终极定义。它是这个让我如此幸运能出生在这里的国家的终极定义。
Because I know you. I don't want to ever hear that anything happened wrong to you. So please be careful. Life is precious. Life is special. Let's do everything we can to preserve it. Thank you very much.
因为我认识你们。我不想听到你们任何人出事。所以请小心。生命是宝贵的。生命是特别的。让我们尽我们所能去保护它。非常感谢。
Thank you so much. Thank you.
非常感谢。谢谢。
Nice.
不错。
Frank told me he's gotten emotional in focus groups before, but usually it's him yelling. This was a first.
弗兰克告诉我他以前在焦点小组中也激动过，但通常是他自己在吼叫。这是第一次。
David Kestenbaum. He's our program's senior editor.
大卫·克斯滕鲍姆。他是我们节目的高级编辑。
[MUSIC - MARGO GURYAN, "PLEASE BELIEVE ME"]
[音乐 - MARGO GURYAN, "PLEASE BELIEVE ME"]
(SINGING) Please believe me. I never lied. I only tried and tried and tried to make you understand. I didn't explain at first, but that was for you. You might have believed the worst, and the worst wasn't true. I did, I did, I swear. I did it all for you.
（歌唱）请相信我。我从来没有撒谎。我只是尝试再尝试再尝试让你理解。我一开始没解释，但那是为了你。你可能相信了最坏的情况，而最坏的情况并不是真的。我做了，我做了，我发誓。我所做的一切都是为了你。
Our program was produced today by Miki Meek, and Aviva deKornfeld, Anna Maria Barry-Jester from Kaiser Health News as our guest editor. People who helped put out show together they include Susan Burton, Ben Calhoun, Dana Chivvis, Sean Cole, Damien Graf, Chana Joffe-Walt, Seth Lind, Lina Misitzis, Katherine Rae Mondo, Nadia Reiman, Ari Saperstein, Robyn Semien, Christopher Swetala, Matt Tierney, and Julie Whitaker.
我们今天的节目由米基·米克（Miki Meek）、阿维娃·德科恩菲尔德（Aviva deKornfeld）制作，来自凯撒健康新闻的安娜·玛丽亚·巴里-杰斯特担任我们的客座编辑。帮助整理节目的人包括苏珊·伯顿（Susan Burton）、本·卡尔霍恩（Ben Calhoun）、达纳·奇维斯（Dana Chivvis）、肖恩·科尔（Sean Cole）、达米恩·格拉夫（Damien Graf）、查娜·乔菲-沃尔特（Chana Joffe-Walt）、塞斯·林德（Seth Lind）、琳娜·米西齐斯（Lina Misitzis）、凯瑟琳·雷·蒙多（Katherine Rae Mondo）、纳迪亚·雷曼（Nadia Reiman）、阿里·萨珀斯坦（Ari Saperstein）、罗宾·塞米恩（Robyn Semien）、克里斯托弗·斯韦塔拉（Christopher Swetala）、马特·蒂尔尼（Matt Tierney）和朱莉·惠特克（Julie Whitaker）。
Our managing editor is Sarah Abdurrahman. Our senior editor is David Kestenbaum. Our executive editor is Emanuele Berry. Special thanks today to Jim Hart, Michelle Smith, Lauren Weber, Hannah Recht, Kat DeBurgh, Marm Kilpatrick, Katie McMahon, Alex Moehring, David Lazer, Crystal Son, Amanda Moss, and KZSC radio at Uc Santa Cruz.
我们的执行主编是萨拉·阿卜杜拉赫曼（Sarah Abdurrahman）。我们的高级编辑是大卫·克斯滕鲍姆。我们的执行编辑是埃马努埃莱·贝里（Emanuele Berry）。今天特别感谢吉姆·哈特（Jim Hart）、米歇尔·史密斯（Michelle Smith）、劳伦·韦伯（Lauren Weber）、汉娜·雷希特（Hannah Recht）、凯特·德伯格（Kat DeBurgh）、马姆·基尔帕特里克（Marm Kilpatrick）、凯蒂·麦克马洪（Katie McMahon）、亚历克斯·莫林（Alex Moehring）、大卫·拉泽（David Lazer）、克里斯托·桑（Crystal Son）、阿曼达·莫斯（Amanda Moss）以及加州大学圣克鲁斯分校的KZSC电台。
Our website thisamericanlife.org, where you can stream our archive of over 700 episodes for absolutely free. Also there's videos. There's lists of favorite shows. There's tons of other stuff there, too. Again, thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange, thanks as always to our program's confounder, Mr. Torey Malatia. You know, he has been so dismayed lately about the politicization of the newspaper crossword puzzle ever since Joe Biden was elected. Don't get him started.
我们的网站 thisamericanlife.org，在那里你可以免费流媒体播放我们超过700集的档案。还有视频。有最喜欢的节目列表。上面还有很多其他东西。再次说明，thisamericanlife.org。《这个美国生活》由PRX（公共广播交换中心）传送到公共广播电台，一如既往地感谢我们节目的联合创始人，托雷·马拉蒂亚（Torey Malatia）先生。你知道，自从乔·拜登当选以来，他最近对报纸填字游戏的政治化感到非常沮丧。别让他开始谈论这个。
There were words used like "communist" and "tyrant" and "fascist."
使用了像“共产主义者”、“暴君”和“法西斯”这样的词。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带回更多《这个美国生活》的故事。
[MUSIC - MARGO GURYAN, "PLEASE BELIEVE ME"]
[音乐 - MARGO GURYAN, "PLEASE BELIEVE ME"]
(SINGING) Please believe me. You'll never get rid of someone, who did. He did. I swear, I did it all you.
（歌唱）请相信我。你永远摆脱不了做过这件事的人。他做了。我发誓，我所做的一切都是为了你。